Sam Dean I know I I jumped right on it
and it was like not hey guys we're gonna
watch a special video today supernatural
BTS stories behind the scenes not though
the bangtan boys not a Korean pop Sam
and Dean monster this comes courtesy
from one of our loyal patronage ex
Ashley Webber from New Zealand
Ashley puts these videos together for us
because it's so easy to get spoiled for
a show that were only four seasons into
I thought it was gonna just be like a
season one bloopers video but actually
put together something else entirely but
yeah we watch Supernatural over at our
patreon page we're like the only
youtubers in the world to have a patreon
we do a weekly Q&A is over there that's
fun and then we also do TV show
reactions stream alongs meaning you sync
up with a timecode i want to be clear
about that
those are full-length reactions and
those shows are agents of shield
stranger things season 3 Gotham a couple
of other shows as well and then there
are shows where we do stream alongs and
have reaction highlights included those
shows that have highlights are
supernatural obviously Hunter hunter
code geass Death Note my hero academia
on the latest season right now movie
included as well attack on Titan and a
couple of other shows as well and he
does music video reactions weekly so
guys going over to our patreon page like
some supernatural or many other shows
along with us let's watch this thing's
Ashley
[Music]
or what pink card sister
oh the squirrel context
[Applause]
yes there's no back you have great
effects in the show
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
these Nick Wrangler who was laying down
behind the couch and he was supposed to
just
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hope that the crowds re-experiencing
it's fine our patients that told us
about this
[Music]
it's okay because I just saw this
episode of how the crab real is
followed him followed camera
[Music]
[Music]
where are they
[Laughter]
[Music]
first
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I just what do you know it's generally
what it's like filming a scene with a
breeze
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just there to do their job well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Thank You Ashley thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll show you what would happen when
tries to be Russians across the set and
word about it to us
[Applause]
I could watch a super kind of
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and it could be like if your you change
the voice
Wow that's right you did something like
this last time thank you
ha it's nice to have a supercut like
personally made for you I'm bummed that
videos over I know I just we need to go
to some of these cons this is the best
time I've had at last 365 days man
already out doing 29 by far is finally
hearing a lot of these stories because
we have like patrons like ash and Doc
toasted Todd good amount who frequently
will comment to us at our patreon page
picture on our comments real at our
patreon page though easily are our
thickest comments sections are for
supernet yeah yeah our most viewed so
makes the most sense
but they'll usually tell us like these
stories and like fun facts about a lot
of these moments oh yeah so a lot of
this was actually familiar and and I had
to sometimes question like wait I
thought we've made you elicit oh wait no
a patron had told us about that before
so as cool though I get a little bit
more in-depth perspective from their
storytelling abilities which by the way
I've been saying it for a while these
guys really should now that supernatural
is over they should just focus on doing
some comedies like Terrigen so they
really should just go into some comedy
yeah they are incredible with a comedic
time it's demonstrated in several
episodes I'm super natural even though
the show's not a comedy but they're
funny and there's some like comedic
episodes but especially here like Jared
Padalecki 'z looseness I've never seen
footage like this where he's this loose
throughout you know man the whole bit
keyboard and just like I'm trying to go
on telling series
taking questions through it and it just
becomes its own little like side
interlude yeah he he seems like the
loosest which I guess at the outset of
the show I might not have expected yeah
you think it would be Jensen yeah cuz
you yeah it gets to be the cool you know
wisecracking one but he's like cool dude
i jared has sort of this demeanor about
him when he you could just tell when
he's locked in a comedic a zone he has
an impish energy yeah there's a bit of
this awkwardness to him whereas jensen
still is always cool even when he's like
self-deprecating or something yeah
he's always cool about it like taking
out the plug from the keyboard moment
you know like he doesn't in such a cool
way yeah yeah where Jared you know Jess
is not she's not short in real life him
he's shorter compared to Jared's Anson
is what is the foot he's a little more
stock he's a little more bulky jared is
he's freakin cut but you know when he's
all kind of the hair to add like a few
extra yeah gosh man he's too both
talented good-looking sexy white strong
males who are also really funny not fair
no not fair they didn't earn it they
just woke up with all this talent yeah
they welcomed pretty great how they were
born but hearing some of these swords
was fascinating he liked the context I
know over oh yeah well cuz like some of
those scenes get so physical and I am
kind of shocked than to hear that you'd
have several actors probably having to
do these maneuvers while not being able
to see very well it made me wonder if
that's why some of their hand-to-hand
fight scenes are shot and edited the way
they are because it's really my only
consistent criticism with the way
they're shot I just chalked it up to it
being a CW show ah there's like 18 cuts
in this two seconds here one they're
throwing fists at each other so I can't
really feel the impact of it but usually
they're you know throwing down
fisticuffs with some demons so they have
to cut around a lot of that it's right
Donnybrook that is yeah
snake story I remember vividly in the
comments yeah the somebody pointed out
like look at that scene again and watch
when they punch in on Jensen because
that's when Jared left the scene iv it
exactly in freakin Jared shoes memo
I would not I don't think I could you
would leave me on the couch I am
absolutely with that snake terrified
it's I'm terrified of snakes sometimes
they bring them on Hollywood Boulevard
some guy or on the Santa Monica Pier
people are gathered and I'm just like I
leave the beach like in the sand crawl
my button that was my fear sounds like
I'm making some lowbrow joke it's got
this weird tingle on my butthole like
somehow just go right up there I want to
break down of how many cases an anal
snake invasion their venomous life
because I feel like I'm I have a fear of
snake I'm not gonna freak out like if
you put one on me I'll hold very still
and respect but I will also be like
don't make a move see ya cuz I saw a
news story when I was a little kid about
a woman who sat on a toilet and there
was a snake and not a hundred eighty
pound snake but it killed her now
looking know I've always told that story
under the impression it went up this
lady's butt hole you know I think it was
my girlfriend who's like why would a
snake do that it took me like 20 years
to realize I don't think in the story
like so myself on it that's led to me
feeling an instant it's gonna go
I mean to be to bear these types of
stories are the reason I always visually
confirm the emptiness of the bulb
engaging with the toy I never just throw
enough a lid and turning around Monroe
but I do bite her on the butt I don't
remember the details I hide that's
evidently drawn my own kind and they had
killed her it's shot her a copy of this
video is not made for kids
goddamn but that also means got yellow
the dollar bill signed isn't that
fascinating
you do I actually don't remember the
episode as well as I remember that
moment because I'm that terrified as
things and they also have the story of
the hellhounds which someone did tell us
about of how excruciating that was and
I'm glad he pointed out when you have
like corn syrup or fake blood on you of
how that sticks oh god I had that like a
few months ago I'm a hairy guy
I had like blood in my chest hair my
style just for two three days that's cuz
it's you have to pull it out yeah parts
I just have to take scissors just cut it
off because it was that is so painful
and I'm like damn even when you're on a
freaking expensive-ass show don't be
well I wonder what it's like for them
react is like you'll have to spend so
long and it made me flashback to like
working in haunts and stuff where you'll
be there for like 12 hours in blood
getting sweaty and then unfunny so then
you'll you know break free again but
then it all set again and then yeah
you're in this like weird limbo where
you can't set your body temperature this
like fake blood is so much more than it
seems
yeah easier to wash out than it looks
but also yeah it'll just like cake your
know if it gets on hairier even like a
scalp hair that oh and then apparently I
Jared did a little ash ketchum maneuver
on him yeah tears helped save his life
mm-hmm hey ma'am it's true love yeah
it's true love's tears you know I'm
referencing right yeah when Pikachu dies
I haven't seen Pokemon the first movie a
long time - dies - dies oh c'mon cry on
Ash there we go that's right ash died
Wow yeah for a moment and then Mewtwo
feels bad and then someone came out and
said we're canceling the show I want
points say about Cassio the guy plays
Castile what's his name
I think it's Misha Collins I thought he
might have been British or Australian
because of how his voice is on the show
I thought he was Irish they're like no
he's actually American and I actually
threw me for a loop I'm gonna bring him
back
Jared and Jett know especially Jenson
they come across like their
personalities off camera are not far
from what you see in the show we can see
where the chemistry boils from yeah
especially with Jenson because he's even
telling his story about the scene where
he's crying
he did such a beautiful job and that's
both of them did too but as especially
Jensen and I attented note to like man I
don't think I've ever seen
Jensen Ackles cry this much before
emotional Dean kudos to the actors who
have to do such heavy cried scenes
because you have to duplicate retakes
which is such a pain is he Thank You
Larry solid gold at all what I got but
before he even said it I was even
thinking Jensen Ackles the human does
not strike me as the kind of guy who
really cries that much and even though
he plays tough emotionally repressed guy
on supernatural I did have a thought
watching this of oh but he must be way
more sensitive in real life if he's an
actor ideally he's probably still a
tough Texan dude but he's got to be a
little bit more sensitive to be an actor
and obviously he is Castillo does not
come across at all like how he does in
the show and he still does do something
different with his voice he dips it it
has a little bit more of that deep
gravel to it because here I'm like how
that that is not at all how he comes
like a regular actor dude so that's what
I thought was amusing about seeing him
here so he's definitely does something
with his voice in his mannerisms and
it's body length everything about him
into show that's not to say like journey
gents are just walking on screen having
a good time they're definitely acting
but especially that performer so that's
what I was picking up on when I was
watching him on the show like they're
always doing something with his voice
it's too it's too cool oh this is too
cool yeah so now it's great time we
watched an episode you know are we gonna
think back to this and have like a new
respect for his transformation
yeah it's true or I'll be distracted and
going sighs I really busy yourself
you're so hey why you pose acting is
being yourself what are you doing but uh
yeah I thought this was a great video
thing thank you so much ash for putting
this together
seriously this is awesome you guys
should go subscribe to Supernatural
conventions I'm a dick I've never
subscribed
what's this garbage supernatural I hate
we share this account you should have
subscribed to you John I should have I
know I am clicking the notification bell
subscribe to Supernatural conventions
click the notification bell do the same
thing for us that'd be dope and
chickasaw patreon and of course
like to end this with a patron of the
day shout out for a man named Derek
Mitchell Derek was able to start off the
new year but bouncing back with getting
a new job or I don't know reprising his
old job I'm not sure which one either
way man gainful employee
this allows you to save up and go to
websites like cam for ultimate calm
you'll have a great time there trust me
you'll enjoy it
Stream mate seriously don't ask him how
we know about it we know about it only
fans yeah see there's a worked in this
industry so go have yourself some fun
celebrate the new year by getting to
know very specific individuals by
Derek's premium snapchat